le feuilleton judiciaire qui opposait
tally rabais maire de trappes et son
principal adversaire au sein du conseil
municipal othman nas roux a donc pris
fin ce 18 août à la plus haute
juridiction administrative a tranché
lors de la campagne électorale le
candidat ali rabais à travers son
association coeur de trappes a bien
distribué des masques des colis
alimentaires ou encore des kits
pédagogiques pour les enfants en les
accompagnant de ses photos à des
opérations qui lui ont permis un gain de
notoriété et qui remettent donc en cause
la sincérité du scrutin pour le conseil
d'état 161 bulletin seulement séparait
les deux candidats arrivés en tête au
second tour de nouvelles élections
devront donc se tenir les juges ont en
revanche décidé de ne pas rendre
inéligible le maire sortant et de
valider ses comptes de campagne ce que
nous a dit le conseil d'état c'est que
le compte de campagne que j'ai présentée
est parfaitement honnête et qu'il est de
bonne foi
en revanche si j'ai un regret c'est de
ne pas avoir fait financer les masques
que j'ai souhaité avec les bénévoles de
l'association que je préside et qui les
fait fabriquer et offerts notamment à
des trappistes j'aurais dû les faire
financer par l'état en réalité et pas
par l'argent des bénévoles de
l'association que je préside et qu'en
réalité si ces masques avait été payée
par les comptes de campagnes par le
contribuable aujourd'hui cette élection
n'aurait pas été annulé je suis
maintenant bien informé pour les
prochaines fois et je ne m'y reprendra
pas mon adversaire finalement tu mènes
menace rouge et mustapha larfaoui
souhaitait que je ne sois pas éligible
c'était leur seul combat en réalité
devant les tribunaux ce combat est perdu
il n'y a pas de sanction d'inéligibilité
ce qui m'interpelle pas ce que ça veut
dire que dans notre pays c'est ce que
j'ai entendu aujourd'hui à trappes on
peut tricher et recommencer ceci étant
dit c'est la décision de justice et donc
à lire à béquilles et ça a été reconnu
par la justice a triché va pouvoir se
représenter et moi je ferai tous tous
pour qu' il y ait un changement attraper
que ce soit pas cette équipe là qu'ils
soient qu'ils soient réélus j'espère
qu'il n'y aura pas de tricherie cette
fois ci puisque nous étions tout près de
réaliser le changement attrape la
dernière fois qu'il a fallu que des
manoeuvres vienne vienne détourner le
scrutin j'espère que cette fois
l'élection sera honnête et je suis
certain que la majorité des trappistes
choisiront un vrai changement pour
trappe et de tourner la page de ce
clientélisme savez acrap on a perdu une
quarantaine de cadres dans les effectifs
municipaux depuis l'élection de monsieur
rabais parce que le climat police le
climat de la municipalité catastrophique
il ya une politisation outrancière
l'utilisation des moyens de la mairie
pour faire de la politique tout ça n'est
pas acceptable et donc je pense qu'au
contraire on peut avoir une forte
mobilisation des électeurs parce que
nous sommes tout près de réaliser de
réussir même le changement n'aura pas
besoin est que le quotidien ne
s'améliore pas ratera malgré la
communication les effets de manche de me
suis rappelé il va falloir que il y ait
un choix clair qui se fait pour les
trappistes alliés arabes et annonce
d'ores et déjà qu'il sera candidat à sa
succession pour othman menaceront en
revanche rien n'est encore décidé il
appelle à l'union des bonnes volontés se
pose en rassembleur dans les prochains
jours une délégation spéciale sera nommé
par le préfet des yvelines pour gérer la
commune à la date de la nouvelle
élection n'a pas encore été communiquée